in birdman edward norton plays a selfish
pretentious actor who nobody wants to
work with because he's so difficult
which allegedly may not be too far from
the truth
at least norton has a sense of humor
about his reputation but it hasn't
helped his career too much
here's why edward norton doesn't get
many movie offers the incredible hulk
in 2008 marvel studios approached norton
to star in their hulk reboot but he
initially turned it down
after meeting with director louis la
terrier norton signed on but with a
ridiculous condition
any suggestions he made to the
screenplay had to be incorporated into
filming
norton evidently did a substantial
rewrite of the movie just weeks before
filming started the terrier shot
as much of norton's script as possible
alongside the original script the
resulting mess was too convoluted for
theaters
marvel executives hated the edit and
ordered the new one with more action
norton more or less hulked out in real
life
and marvel resented norton's meddling so
much that norton got the boot in favor
of mark ruffalo when it came time for
the avengers
marvel took the rare step of issuing a
statement about why norton was dropped
saying they wanted an actor who embodies
the creativity and collaborative spirit
of our other talented cast members
in short they were sick of him and
didn't like him when he was angry
or at all red dragon the la times
reported that in 2002 during the filming
of the silence of the lamb's prequel red
dragon
norton showed up on set with brand new
totally unsolicited script pages that
he'd written for himself
director brett ratner and his producers
didn't take kindly to norton's demands
to film the scenes and an argument
ensued it's just one of many instances
where norton ignored the basic chain of
command that makes movie sets run
smoothly
so it's easy to see how norton was
beginning to set up his career to crash
and burn
even back in 2002
frieda in the 2002 biopic about artist
frida carlo
norton played nelson rockefeller the
billionaire who commissioned carlo's
husband diego rivera to paint a mural in
new york's rockefeller center
norton's then girlfriend salma hayek had
been trying to get the movie made for
years
wanting to get every detail perfect she
asked norton to conduct additional
research
and use whatever he found to rewrite the
free to screenplay that had already been
completed norton has since taken credit
for the final cut
but the writer's guild refused to credit
him since he violated their rules norton
trashed the wga in a 2007
interview with the av club saying i
wrote frida i wasn't a member of the
writer's guild and i didn't get paid i
just got sort of shafted by them quite
frankly
death to smoochie not even the costume
department is safe from norton's
interference
during production of the 2002 dark
comedy death to smoochie the film's
costume designer jane rum presented
norton with a wide variety of clothes
for his character but that wasn't good
enough for norton without anyone's
knowledge
norton commissioned armani to design him
the ultimate in hippie chic
a suit made of actual hemp rome later
told premier magazine that naughton made
her deal with all of the paperwork
associated with getting the suit made
and center set
rather than you know letting her do her
job to begin with american history x
norton was nominated for an oscar for
the 1998 drama american history x
but he didn't just star in the movie he
also edited it not that anybody had
asked him to
during the shoot norton and director
tony k reportedly clashed about norton's
character and dialogue but things got
really bad during the editing phase k
had created a tight 95 minute cut of the
film but when norton saw it he thought
that k had cut too much
not wanting to upset their star the
production company relented to norton's
demand that he make his own norton
central cut of the movie which clocked
in at well over two hours that's the
version that made it to theaters which
upset kay
prompting him to ask the director's
guild to remove his name from the film's
credits and replace it with humpty
dumpty his request was denied and his
200 million dollar lawsuit against the
production didn't fly either
k took out 40 ads in trade papers
eviscerating norton and told a reporter
the actor was a narcissistic dilettante
who rapes the film
geez it goes without saying that the two
haven't worked together again
gee whiz thanks for watching click the
looper icon
to subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love too